are you being honest yes would you lie
to me I would never love you dick I
can't trust you it's either all or
nothing you can either split or steal
get ready reveal in three
two one
[Music]
who do you think is greedier men or
women women only men definitely not
women definitely I'm not really in like
every aspect I think women are greedier
more materialistic in certain things
first man in my opinion are more simple
women are a little bit more emotional we
can have empathy and Men that's easier
for them to kind of take emotion out of
it so it's easy for them to be a little
bigger year and okay okay I love the
discussion I love the discussion but we
have to start the game for round one
you're gonna try to collect the most
money for your team in five terms one by
one you will come to the table and face
your opponent if both players choose
blue they will split the money in front
of them and end their turn if one
chooses red and the other chooses blue
the blue player loses and the red player
wins the money and continues playing if
both teams choose red they both end
their turn and lose any money previously
won during a continuous Turn Only the
team with the most money by the end will
proceed to the next round what will you
do with the prize if you win it Dave I'm
here for friendship
I have a surgery on Wednesday but
Seventeen hundred dollars out of pocket
I was recently fired so I need to pay my
rent and pay some bills okay you each
will get two minutes to discuss the
order of the lineup and strategy now
this first round we should try and get
their trust I feel like initially he's
gonna go oh yeah yeah let's put split
and then come in immediately have them
think that we're gonna like share the
money yeah
show them that splitting is in their
best interest yeah unless they still
exactly yeah I'm worried about putting
you early like we gave too much yeah
they were so there's some friction I
feel like they didn't steal against you
Ali is definitely gonna try to steal
some money Vermont he really was just
quick to be like we're greedy so I think
that like kind of just feel definitely
feel it out
can I have my first players come in
oh this is the first turn
we'll be playing for 50 dollars
you'll have one minute for this turn go
okay so I'll be fully honest and
transparent like I said I have a surgery
coming up so I personally would rather
[Music]
split the money versus take the chance
and none of us walk out here with
anything this fifth failures how
beneficial for yourself do you think
it'll be toward that much money for a
surgery I mean anything is beneficial
and I should trust you not to steal
you're looking at me very intense white
hey you know what eye contact eye
contact is important when we're talking
about money and why is it that you know
what I have your words okay time's up
you can either split or steal please
reveal your decision in three
two
one
okay okay I can trust you I can trust
you good I hope
for this turn we'll be playing for 100
I feel like I feel like we can split it
I feel like we can split it as well
why should I trust you in splitting
because I was here to make friends you
came to a game show to be friends okay
what can I trust you because I feel like
you guys were pretty hard on us earlier
I think women are greedier but I didn't
say no that is your teammate which
actually I would work against me though
are you being honest yes would you lie
to me I would never lie to you today you
would never lie to me I'm making eye
contact with you how's your very strong
eye contact yes okay okay time is up I'm
so nervous
please review your decision in three
two one
[Music]
nice work Dave
don't be trustworthy
I'm Molly Imani nice to meet you for
this turn we have a mystery envelope you
can either split or steal if you decide
to split the mystery envelope you will
each get an envelope
but it may be an uneven split I'm
honestly feeling a split I think the
mystery is supposed to entice us to
steal it the rest of our team split and
we should make that decision as well
just like everyone else how do I know I
can trust you
I'm a man of my word
and I have
because if we both do we both lose
nothing and Jubilee Woods we have to win
you're good with that whether or not we
get the same amount yeah I'm good with
that regardless okay
I trust you I just C2 three
two one
look at that thank you good man I
respect your word I respect you as well
so I have an A and B envelope you decide
which one you want for your word I'll
let you make the decision affiliates
[Music]
thank you players please go back I was
going to be the one that was gonna steal
but right in the moment my brain was
don't be that guy but I should have been
that guy we're playing for
two hundred dollars
let's both walk away with a hundred
let's I was gonna say I mean it's easy
are we gonna keep this going interesting
I can trust you
Pinky Promise means a lot though okay in
three two one
we can trust each other all right this
is now the final turn I feel like we're
only drivers
a reminder that only the team with the
most money will proceed to round two
right now
each team has 175 dollars plus a mystery
envelope turn number five
four hundred dollars you can either
split or steal one minute begin now okay
Dave I'm going to be honest with you I'm
going to steal this around but I promise
to give you and your team
a share of the money
at the end so it's in your best interest
to split but then we wouldn't be able to
go into the next round or just be the
girls in the next round or else I dare
you everyone
leaves with nothing
that is all well collaboration you
cannot consult your team do we zero out
just to understand the rules do all the
balances zero out no just no one takes a
400.
all right you were honest with me I'm
gonna be honest with you I don't see any
incentive to I can't trust you it's
either I'll or nothing
yeah
you can either split or steal
if you both steal you lose the 400 if
you split you each get 200.
but if one steals gets the entire 400.
you ready reveal in three
two one
Patty what I couldn't trust you
now now we
really strong it's like I have a nuke
and I was like oh no I told you I'd give
some of it and now you're leaving with
less you both decided to steal so no one
takes a four hundred dollars now we need
to reveal what's in the mystery envelope
okay
we have the players back here
as it stands we're at a tie
175 dollars for the men 175 dollars for
the women but we still have the mystery
on the lobes we will now reveal
the value amounts inside these envelopes
this will decide who goes to the next
round
are you two ready I'm ready ready to
lose
all right get ready to reveal at the
same time in three
two
one reveal
the woman won
240 dollars and the men got zero dollars
so the women have won with 415 dollars
for round one but it's not over we're
going to round two
um I'm very salty I have trust issues
now if I could go back
I would have stole when I had the chance
so that we could have took all the girls
money and made it to round two ladies
welcome to round two
you must decide as a team if you want to
split
415 or steal it all to make things more
interesting
I'll increase the pot
to one thousand dollars if you steal it
all for yourself the rules are simple if
you all decide to split you'll evenly
split 415 dollars
if one chooses to steal and the others
split then the one who chose red takes
one thousand dollars if more than one
person chooses to steal then no one wins
and you go back home empty-handed
you have three minutes to discuss and
decide I'm happier to steal if you guys
split I will promise you both that I
will split it evenly amongst all of us
sounds like a good plan I'm pretty sure
I trust you I just want to make a rule
you can't
okay
well
I think the easiest way or what makes
the most sense
would be for us to split we don't want
to chance somebody stealing or more than
one of us stealing yeah do we want to
walk away with nothing right yeah
I agree yeah
split
let's split this 4 15. that's the only
way that we're all gonna leave with
something yeah because if more than one
guaranteed takes like we are going to
leave with nothing yeah
all right so I guess we're all splitting
yeah we are we got what's good let's get
some money
okay time is up you can either split or
steal have you decided
yeah
yes I hope you guys chose wisely
get ready to reveal
in three
two
what
none of us are trustworthy people not at
all I guess greed spoke louder today how
do you all feel not good I came here for
all or nothing I was really here to take
it all I kind of kind of expected it to
be honest honestly I was down to split
but I definitely had the inkling that
some of my teammates were going to steal
and I was like well if they're going to
steal they're not going to take this
money away from me I feel like
[Music]
I don't think women are greedier but I
think we all came here to win some money
when you put money in front of people I
think that people can just get greedy
because the idea of that is really nice
I'm happy the way everything played out
I'm just happy no one won honestly
because if I can't win no I should have
it